out of nowhere I remembered his dad ran
up like a full-grown adult dad like same
age as my dad he ran up and this Dad
just grabbed me by the collar and he
just started socking me in my face whoa
yeah and he kept going why'd you hit him
why'd you hit him and he just kept
[ __ ] me up in my face and then my dad
ran over and my dad got in a fight with
that guy oh [ __ ]
[Music]
welcome back to another Splendid episode
of the careful boys we have with us
today we got Chris Sosa here today
[Music]
daily and then we have the rest of the
usual boring ass people [ __ ] you dude
[ __ ] you man I got a question today I
wanted to know from you guys it's
genuinely genuinely I would like to know
when was the first time you got your ass
kicked
like you got in a fight you got your ass
does parents count no it doesn't count
that [ __ ] happens like in a fight in a
real fight
um mine is really Vivid
uh mine was uh when I was
I think okay I was in first grade and
this is the part that kind of sucks I'm
friends with this kid's older brother
and this kid's little brother whooped my
ass so I don't even remember his name
this guy could have just been like some
big ass [ __ ] kindergartner or some
[ __ ] but I still live in like um like in
one of those neighborhoods where it's
like so if you're if you're familiar
with like Cerritos or like Cyprus or
whatever it'll be like here's the
entrance to the neighborhood and I'll
have like a name like the Mayflower or
some [ __ ] right and then and then you go
in and the neighborhoods like [ __ ]
all these streets and stuff so like
everyone in that neighborhood all hung
up
and I don't even remember what happened
but I remember me and the kid's little
brother his older brother was even there
just me and him
got into an argument and he kicked me in
the mouth and my [ __ ] lips just
exploded in the in those I was just
bleeding all over the place and I don't
even know how to fight and I don't even
know what fighting was I don't even know
how to return violence or anything like
that and he just [ __ ] took all the
YMCA karate skills and he just kept
roundhousing me in the face over and
over and over and over yeah like he was
like Van Damme against Chung Lee [ __ ]
like like like one and then [ __ ]
looking at me and [ __ ] because I'm so
stunned I don't even moving and he's
like two it just keeps turning around
like this bro you didn't even have
instincts to go I should move I was so
shocked I was just like boom and I'm
like
boom I'm like what the [ __ ]
but it was just over and over yeah and
then I went home I ran home I was like
crying because I couldn't even believe
like of my friend what would hurt me
like that and that was the first fight I
ever wow dude that's not a fight oh
that's like a you got your ice cream
yeah you got jokes well yeah I mean that
is the first time you got your ass
kicked I just yeah I mean it's uh it's
Nick's record you know
oh yeah Jesus Christ
but I was also 21.
I wasn't 11. you know hey last time my
instincts you guys made the same amount
of revenue from your fights now shut up
dude hold me back dude hold me back
I had a uh uh a TKO fight uh that I lost
but it was an amateur fight with this
kid why'd you look at me when he said
he's actually well since you were like
eight or something right you say what
you've been boxing since you were like
eight years yeah yeah yeah so it was one
thing was like uh like 11 or 12 but this
kid is a it's also my first time
fighting like a true like Mexican
fighter where they're all body shots all
hooks I'm On Top I'm just you know
saying maybe a hook every now and then
but we're just going here you know and
I've never felt a body punch before this
is my first time like getting it like
hit it oh my gosh like the air oh I
didn't even know what that was how old
are you I was like 10 11 like 10 11 12
in that area but
um this was also like like I've won my
fights up until this moment I'm chilling
I remember my getting my hands wrapped
and I'm like eating sour straws like
just like kicking it like it's gonna
we're gonna run this real quick you know
yeah and I got hit yo and it and then uh
I remember like sinking and the ref saw
it so it was enough to where he made it
an eight count and I was I was so like
scared I'm like I'm getting an eight
count right now like what like it was a
whole body shot body shot and I couldn't
really breathe and I'm not and my dad's
over here just like breathe breathing
I'm just like what is happening yo and I
remember whenever they said like you
know box they let me keep going he's
just kept going again boost the body and
oh my gosh they called it yo I lost I
lost off of a detail and that was and
he's still a professional boxer actually
he fought recently um on the undercard
of um who there was a there was a big
fight like two Saturdays ago but his
name is uh um
yes yeah oh wow he was the coach he was
the code uh Main Event wow Miguel Flores
yeah yeah and they were there was a draw
that one was a draw but um that's my guy
he's from he's from Houston uh uh and
and I always I always like give him [ __ ]
for that one because I'm just like
[ __ ] like he had he got me when
he was eight years old dude no stop
fights like kid fights earlier oh you
say what they stopped the kid fights
earlier like let's see like oh the kids
hurt so like this just stop a little
Knockouts yeah no like they get they
need blood I didn't know I don't know
like I got stopped to think it was uh I
think it was a third round it was a
second or third round but yeah he got me
have you been in a fight before like or
just like when you were young I've never
been in the street fighter oh yeah yeah
I've never been not outside
wow you never got man [ __ ] been
waiting to unleash these [ __ ]
no man I've heard that from so many
boxers yeah like even Brandon
tussle but that was just like like get
separated and so like that and even then
that was in elementary this is gonna
sound like [ __ ] but I honestly have
the same [ __ ] story and I have the
same I've never fought outside the ring
but my first fight was inside a ring
boxing because my uncles owned this
um you know fighting company called
satellite boxing in Arlington Virginia
and so my dad took me there because my
dad was the general manager of it right
so they were they were all working on it
together and we actually had this guy he
was a really good fighter named Keith
Holmes he was like he was like really
coming up at the time and he was like he
was like winning all kinds of [ __ ] so
like I got to meet him and hang out with
him and [ __ ] it was really cool but um
it was my cousin Frankie's birthday
party and so we all went to satellite
boxing and like they had like a ref and
like they had all the kids like get
weighed up and [ __ ] and then uh we
didn't actually weigh in they just were
like hey who wants to like who's what
weight and I didn't [ __ ] know what
weight I was have you been training I
haven't been training or anything like
that but I was around Keith a lot like
because he would just come in all the
time and like hang out my uncles my dad
and stuff and so I would I would um my
uncle's all watch Boxing every [ __ ]
weekend with my dad right so I watched
all that [ __ ] and we watched Tyson a lot
and so I remember getting in the ring
and and they're basically like who wants
who who weighs what and I [ __ ] up I
was just like I weigh that and then they
put me against like the biggest [ __ ]
kid yeah and I [ __ ] up with that for
sure and then they you know we have the
we have the pads on [ __ ] and then I have
the um the boxing gloves and same as you
my first time getting punched was like
to the gut and I was like like lost my
breath immediately and then it's just
survival after that like oh [ __ ] like I
actually but I was mad at him after that
and so I'm like punching but I don't
[ __ ] know how to punch or anything
like that I'm like eight years old and
it was just that it was just pure like
I'm gonna get you into until I hope oh
man I hope they [ __ ] call it already
please call it already yeah and that was
it that was my first fight and that was
my only real fight holy [ __ ] yeah yeah
I've always just been good about calling
it reading the reading the situation
that I can like I'll just get out of it
you know I don't look for it I don't try
to you know I mean that's not my style I
know that I can defend myself but at the
same time that somebody is like trying
to get Rowdy they trying to come I just
I'm out you know what I mean see I have
the same skills you I've never been in a
fight outside of anything I can also
reach it but the difference is I can't
defend myself
um now you can't have to read it maybe I
can but you could move yourself out of
the way to try putting the fish like
well you guys never
it's called instincts you guys never
just gonna jump
like I've never been jumped by Bullet I
thought that was normal we're like
you're just like eating lunch or
something and then someone comes up and
just punches you in the face of your
stomach or whatever or like and then you
get them back or whatever that never
happened I've also only been in like
push scuffles yeah push scuffles maybe
was about to escalate but then like
either de-escalated or some [ __ ] what
about like in like the like schools
where like two people walk by they bump
shoulders right and then when they bump
shoulders and turn around all of a
sudden both sides of the hallway is
staring and you have to throw it down
but you already know bar every time I
bought the truck they turn around what's
on
out of here we walked out of it
the um one of my earliest memories was
when I was four and that's the first
time I got like beat up and it was the
weirdest situation and I I think my dad
was there and he'd probably be so
surprised I even remember this but
um there was a store called fedco it was
over in Cerritos yeah it was kind of
like it was that South and Gridley
actually was that something Gridley and
then not a lot of people remember that
across from there there was a fedco
furniture store as well and um the
furniture store was it was basically the
same store but it was all like couches
and [ __ ] and it turned into Ethan Allen
yeah a lot of uh tragedies have gone
down on that property it's a dangerous
Street man it's harder me and my sister
were in there and we were like playing
like on the you know when you're a kid
you play on the beds and [ __ ] and then
we were just like jumping around and
this other kid came up and he was
smaller than me and he kept trying to
get on the bed but I kept pushing him
down and then out of nowhere I
remembered his dad ran up like a
full-grown adult dad like same age as my
dad he ran up and this Dad just grabbed
me by the collar and he just started
socking me in my face whoa what yeah and
he kept going why'd you hit him why'd
you hit him and he just kept [ __ ] me
up in my face and then my dad ran over
and my dad got in a fight with that guy
oh [ __ ] yeah and it was like this
weird-ass situation and then I remember
I didn't understand anything about it
and I was like what I remember asking my
dad like was that like the bad guy oh
because I couldn't tell like how old
were you four years old like a bad guy
from the movie I just remember I wasn't
in school yet yeah I wasn't in I wasn't
in kindergarten yet so I remember I was
four getting socked by a man
he looked like Charles Bronson you know
like one of those guys yeah and then and
then I remember the conversation after
him and my dad stopped fighting my dad
was like my dad was like what what were
you thinking like he was asking the guy
and the guy was like oh I was just
trying to stop him I was trying what
that's I just remember those words
exactly the guy was saying they was
trying to stop me but I distinctly
remember like being held like did that
mess you up as a kid it didn't because
about it now like as an adult too early
did you because I didn't cry with a big
hero like he fought you know what it's
it's so early that it didn't even it
computed it a bunch of times before his
dad came yeah yeah he was just days
still he had the [ __ ] birds and [ __ ]
and the Stars it was just like weird
like un uh understandable data in my
brain I was just like okay this happened
the dad punched me and like I'd never
been punched but then I realized that
like I all I remember thinking was like
where the good guys right and that's the
bad guy yeah I just remember like asking
my dad that and then it was it was
really awkward jeez I have a funny story
and uh in fourth grade because it was
like so ironic so I was at this like
after school like
um my tutoring place it's kind of like a
daycare but you like work on homework
and [ __ ] and then I'm waiting for my mom
to get picked up there's a kid that was
like sitting on a chair because they
have a movie that they rolled out so all
the kids just watching movies while the
parents come the kid left and then so I
go sit down
and then uh the kid comes back like 30
minutes later and he goes hey that was
like my seat and I'm like oh you left
you know that was just like the rollback
that if you leave then it's open for
whatever right so I sit there so I guess
that kid gets all [ __ ] pissed or
whatever later on I found out my mom uh
car is outside so I go uh to the back to
get my backpack and when I'm getting my
backpack like this
I just feel a leg come up and [ __ ]
hit me in my [ __ ] balls
I don't know what happened maybe I was
like my balls were too high or some [ __ ]
at that time
um no they were kicked in you but it
didn't even affect me I turn around and
I'm like what the [ __ ] it's that kid's
older sister so my in my uh wait the
same one from your last story
it's a kicking family older sisters my
immediate reaction is to kick her in the
chest
boom I'm a [ __ ] kicker in the chest
and then this is like you know like the
martial arts warm-ups it's like you kick
right and you kick and you kick so I
just walked her ass [ __ ] down I'm
[ __ ] like five times faster back to
back to back let's do a right boob left
boo right there she falls down she
[ __ ] she's like all crying and [ __ ]
the teacher is like here's the commotion
what the hell is going on and then like
oh she's beating up my sister and I was
like Bart go sit over there and then so
it's just waiting she sits me down I'm
on the stairs like at the bottom stair
like this and then um she pulls my mom
in and wants to like tell my mom what
happens that girl's boyfriend finds out
that I kicked her so he comes out you
kicked her more than once he comes up to
me and he goes what the [ __ ] so he tries
to kick me in the nuts but since I'm
sitting on the stairs he kicks the
[ __ ] stairs he goes
I'm just like what the is this like a
[ __ ] nut kicking movie everyone
yeah dude how could you never told this
story I wonder if he would have kicked
you in the face he would have been like
what and they kept kicking you again
your weakness
chill that is so to be like doing this
marching band kick against a girl
earliest memories of a of a hard [ __ ]
beat down was uh there's these two
neighbor Brothers in the cul-de-sac with
me uh Marcos and Frankie right we're
like maybe first grade or some [ __ ] like
that the older brother was my friend for
some reason he wasn't there and I was
playing with Frankie and we were inside
uh the living room we were playing ninja
turtles we're fighting over one of them
like Leonardo or whatever and then so we
get into like a [ __ ] pool fight all
that [ __ ] and then like he grabs uh the
Ninja Turtle [ __ ] van slabs it over
me [ __ ] starts kicking me right yeah
I'm getting [ __ ] up I'm going on and
like and I'm like crying and [ __ ] and
I'm so [ __ ] sad and then like his
mom's like what the [ __ ] and then
afterwards like I can't take it anymore
so I turn over and I started [ __ ]
back fisting his head like that and then
his mom just tells Marcos right so then
he's my friend and I thought like
everything was chill because like this
it's chill now right so I'm on my
bicycle I'm like going up and down the
street and then he's like Hey Joe and
I'm like hey and then he comes up to me
and I think he's just gonna talk to me
and he just starts [ __ ] wailing on me
I fall off of my bicycle and he's just
kicking the [ __ ] out of me and the way
he fought me versus his little brother
it was like a real [ __ ] beat down and
I'm just like we're supposed to be
friends and I didn't get like hey that
[ __ ] was between me and your little
brother why are you doing this to me now
and then I'm like we're supposed to be
friends and then after that I just went
home like on my bicycle and I was like
crying and [ __ ] and I'm like
I don't think we're friends anymore
foreign
did you see the Turtle van after that
and kind of think of it differently I
wanted a turtle van so bad dude
until this became one of that turtle man
yeah it just came out of nowhere just
started banging on you with it I I
forgot like how we started to like fight
but I remember at the end I was on the
ground and he [ __ ] threw the Turtle
van on top of me and I was like crying
like no and then like when we were sat
down and [ __ ] and I was like I couldn't
take it anymore because I felt like such
a [ __ ] I turned around I just started
[ __ ] back lifting his head like that
was it a metaphor for how you guys were
fighting over Ninja Turtles that you got
beat up with the Turtle fan
I think it was just poetic
I think I told the story before on here
but I I recall me getting my aspie now
um
it was uh it was say that story again
I'm gonna go over there and whoop your
ass bro I'm just kidding
I Just Met You Chris I'm sorry I'll jump
in on it low level jokes
you were his only hope man I know dude
you can't be doing that you're already
one of the [ __ ] levels on Game of
Death for me dog [ __ ] you're right all
right you don't have chocolate
yeah
this is great give this guy a raise I'm
trying to get a job here
you can always work at FedEx
all right so I remember being on uh in
elementary school when I was on the
field
and uh I had just I told this story it's
so dumb
um I had just learned the uh the f word
the uh that rhymes with maggot oh oh
[ __ ] yeah I just learned it you know
when you just learned something you just
want to use it you don't know what it
means and yeah yeah I learned the sound
I didn't learn the meaning
some people might say it's a great word
some people might say it the way you
heard it the intonation as well it's a
solid combination of letters
in terms of combination there was also
this time frame where there was this
rule going around this epidemic right
where uh when the bell rings you freeze
you can't move otherwise you get written
up with a citation with them safeties
that have like orange vests and [ __ ]
right on the playground after Reese's
when the bell rings you have to [ __ ]
freeze you drop your ball and [ __ ] like
that you can't pick it up you know what
I'm talking about she's like stop
playing everybody has to [ __ ] freeze
right well so uh right before the end of
recess I looked this one kid who like
did something or said something I call
him a stupid f word right yeah and the
bell rang so I thought it was safe yeah
so you said it at Mid yeah so I said it
right before the building I was like
haha you can't get to me right but then
he started walking towards me because
he's like would you say that and I was
looking at him I was in my mind I was
like you're supposed to freeze all right
you're still frozen you're like wait
belt wrong bell wrong
and I stayed you know I'm a man of Honor
so I stayed Frozen the whole time yeah
yeah and he walked over and he literally
took me and he threw me on the floor oh
my God and so I was a sucker Frozen
still crying and that's when I learned
that you can't just call people that who
would have known you didn't know it was
an insult no you thought it was a cool
word you just hear [ __ ] as a kid I used
to say the N word all the time because
when you know my friends I was like what
first second grade
I learned it then all my you know half
of my classmates were black
I thought it meant friend because that's
because everyone uses it he uses it they
use like and kids learn words through
context not by the dictionary right so
then like one day
um
they used to sing this song this was
like a nursery rhyme for or like like a
bad nursery rhyme where it was like oh
have you heard of this a fight a fight a
black and a white the end had a gun so
the white had to run nine that was we
used to say the nursery rhyme wow do you
say this so sweet so it was no it was
they we had the easily Crazy Ones at our
elementary school and and then there
used to be another one that was like
um there's more your mama something she
hit the pole and then her titty rolled
it was like it was like some [ __ ] like I
don't know it was like that one sounds
cool it was funny the Spanish ones but
anyways
I was singing that song with my friends
right we were waiting in line to buy
snacks from the snack lady and then so
um we were like I was the only Asian kid
but I was singing it and and then the
the lunch lady was like Joseph go back
to the end of the line and I was like oh
[ __ ] what did I do and I was always
getting in trouble at this time so I was
like I don't know what I did man and
then so when I got back to the front
skating your own crime and you're like
you know you're like they're like you're
in big trouble and I'm like what I just
want to buy snacks you know and then
like they were trying to explain to me
the significance of the word and all
that and I'm like I don't [ __ ]
understand and the other thing is my
black friends were singing it but they
didn't say anything to them you know so
I was just like why I don't understand
what the [ __ ] what did I do wrong here
and then they still the kids still said
that word to each other and [ __ ] so I
was just like all my n words say the N
where
I think it's such a hard word for kids
to understand yeah actually like in
third or four grow up around it yeah so
much [ __ ] history attached to it and
you don't know like the real meaning
because the way that it's used with your
friends yes and then the way that
they're they're talking about it so I'm
just like this [ __ ] and I don't even
know what race really was at that age
you know like you think everybody's kind
of like the same group right yeah so
then like it was such a weird experience
I remember saying and I remember I got
beat up because I would use that word
and then like and then like people would
just like fight me and I still didn't
know what it was and I'm like maybe I
should stop using it that never came
into my mind it's just I'm still using
it like an idiot you know yeah I had a
shorty I dated that uh through blows at
me for sure and I had a it was one of
those fetal positions you gotta just
take it right you're a good man dude
yeah you know saying it was one of those
uh one of those situations classic
domestic violence but I was in it
the only street fight you've been in was
when a girl was beating your ass off
yeah she she was throwing blows and
stuff and uh I was just we were dating
so like I actually was like training her
how to box and [ __ ] so I remember like
looking at her back foot like oh [ __ ]
I was like that's pretty good you know
it's great technique yeah yeah yeah your
hips yeah I was kind of giving her
advice like I put the weight on your
back foot
I was making her want to beat your ass
like that oh man it was a uh it was a
drunk night it was actually it was
actually a night where it was uh uh I
was performing this night and it was one
of those like she used to she would go
to all of my shows and stuff she would
support me and stuff but uh she was just
got out of work she didn't really want
to go to the show but she's like I'm
gonna go we're already like bickering
earlier that day so she was already
upset so I just remembered like uh this
was one of those shows it was in East
L.A little hole in the wall uh a bar uh
show we're still trying to I'm trying to
like her she like she likes ludicrous so
like trying to lighten up the mood on
the way there jamming some old school
Ludacris and just you know just like
we're good everything's cool
um she we're after the after my
performance it was cool and she's like
she saw on the menu like there's like
chalkboard like how the the drinks and
so she's they saw adios [ __ ] and
I don't know if y'all heard of adios but
yeah but it has for those who don't know
it has four different vodkas in it a lot
of [ __ ] it is very well designed yeah
she got an adios [ __ ] and uh
audios that [ __ ] went because
after that yo I just I just I remember
before buying it I would go like yo we
ain't gonna We're not gonna like trip
tonight right we're not gonna get back
this is like kind of like a pattern
don't worry about it this is kind of a
pattern yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah I
just I just remember like man oh my God
after after the uh after the show I was
talking to the producer she was ready to
go but I was like talking about more
shows and stuff like that and uh she was
waiting for me outside that was her
thing she was pissed that I had two
gloves on she was waiting outside yeah
yo she was like punching bricks and [ __ ]
came outside and she was just like why
the [ __ ]
did you not come for me and give me
outside I talked about the shoes like in
my face and I was like I was like in the
car it's all good you know what I'm
saying and I hope she was fine bro oh
bro I mean she was like you know she was
a cutie you're dealing with this for a
reason yeah yeah but man when we got
home yo this was already like we've
already talked about like yo we're gonna
de-este like if this is a situation
de-escalate it I'm gonna sleep in the
other type we had a two bedroom uh and
so I slept in the other room she did not
like that [ __ ] she was like coming like
jiggling the door or [ __ ] I remember yo
there's like a uh there was a she she
like providing horror I remember her
walking away and I'm kind of just like
all right she's gonna like go to sleep
but I'm here in the kitchen like opening
the drawer and like jiggling and like
getting the night so she she had a she
had got a knife this I know she was
hella drunk too because she tried to
like like oh my god oh open the door
like through the oh [ __ ] Jimmy the
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah and we had those
old school doors like a butter knife you
could just go like that you don't say
like that's why I know she was just out
of it bro like she was I was just like
hey yo put the knife up you know what
I'm saying I opened the door if you if I
hear the we have wood floors I was like
Drop The Knife and then I'll open the
door just so I can like I'm about to get
the [ __ ] out of here you know what I'm
saying and I open the door she's all on
my face and [ __ ] I'm just like yo I'm a
dip I'm gonna go to my cousin's crib you
know shaking house oh my [ __ ] it's like
a nightmare this is one of those
situations yeah yeah so I was getting
you know getting my things and stuff
like that getting ready to get out of
there but uh yeah she was blocking the
door blocking it out the way and then I
was just I was just trying to get out of
there she that's when she finally like
blacked out she knew I was gonna leave
she pushed me and then I like kind of
like stumbled like onto the bed and she
started like going off and I'm just I'm
just you know eating them up and then
that's when like I looked like when she
was done I looked at her she knew she
[ __ ] up too all right I'm out of here
you know what I'm saying and I remember
she was oh my gosh she was so like I
have my little Chihuahua I looked a
little doggy and I'm like you guys are
shivering and [ __ ]
I was getting my things but I also I
also went and got my dog too because I'm
dipping but I got my dog because I was
like I don't know how mad that she is
yeah she was so she was like marketing
oh you're gonna get your dog you get
your dog like you're me oh
dude I remember getting in my car I
drove like I didn't even like At first I
didn't even go to anywhere yet I just
drove like a couple blocks down and it
was just in my car like what the [ __ ]
just happened I was like oh crazy you're
punching your head he said what she's
punching your head she was just wailing
she was just like yeah just kind of like
yeah just mad just like everything just
yeah yeah
don't create bits of your loved ones
yeah like this what happens yeah that's
it was a it was a whole thing yeah he
did a whole stand-up bit about how she
can't decide what to eat yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]